want this
yes um all right so I'm going to talk
about complementarities and
externality well we know that you know
in Market Design This is a corner of
Market design literature which is quite
challenging and difficult and the reason
is that uh when preference is exhibit a
just a very slight degree of
complimentarity and suddenly we don't
have um stable matching in two-sided
Market nor competitive equilibrium in
one-sided Market anymore right um yet we
cannot really ignore these issues
because these are really crucial
elements of a lot of practical
applications uh so my talk is a little
bit of survey talk I want to show you
server works and really convey to you a
relatively General method to construct
approximate Solutions in both one-sided
and two-sided market and the features of
this method is is not really follow the
type of beautiful greedy algorithms that
Al explain this morning uh but rather a
non-gritty approach and let me kind of
step back and explain what it is right
uh so in computer science with first
type algorithm that we learn we call the
gitty algorithm we essentially we build
the solution piece by piece and every
time we only look one step ahead right
and it works well for server problems
like minimum spanning tree minimum base
of the mids um but unfortunately on a
broad l in or even give extra constraint
for this problem the 3 algorithm fail
Mis uh and then there's another
techniques which I learned a lot from
your approximation algorithm book uh
that is LP relaxation right so we write
any optimization program as an integer
program and we relax my variable is not
Z one but any variable between zero and
one and we solve this linear program and
if you're are lucky the solution came
out to be an integer then perfect uh if
not then we're going to try server
methods to kind a brow this fractional
solution through a nearby integer
Solutions uh and the beauty of this
approach is that it works for much
broader range of problems but also uh
give insight into why the structure of
the problems where the gitty algorithm
works okay um so I want to convey to you
that in Market design the same inside
actually home right so the two beautiful
building blocks Cornerstone Market
design that different accept them
algorithms or tment process in Market
design competitive equilibrium actually
just gitty algorithms and it works very
well when preference are
substitutes
and without this conditions not only
that this greedy athm stop working we
have a more serious problem that you
know stable Solutions or competitive
equilibrium doesn't exist anymore okay
so the approach that I am proposing is
called relax and rout um so first I'm
going to assume that in this market
things are
divisible and I'm come up with a
fractional stable or fractional
equilibrium and I'm going to Route it
okay um so this approach turns out to be
quite flexible work well for preferences
Beyond substitutes and importantly also
give insight into why we have the
original result when we have
substitute okay uh so I'm going to give
you a few example case studies uh of
this approach the first one is table
matching uh so everybody here knows what
stable matching is but I'm going to give
you an example in stad definitions here
I have two hospital and two doctors and
the preference are given over here and I
have two possible matching matching
number one the two bow and I denote it 1
0 0 1 and this one is 0 1 1 0 okay so I
can express this matching as a matching
polop where each of the row of the
constraints correspond to the constraint
that I can sum of these two edges are at
most one um and each of the columns are
just the variables of these edges uh and
I can really Express an order for each
of of the row mimicking the preference
of these agents okay um so there's a
concept here that a solution dominates a
column it means that there exist
somewhere a
constraint that is
binds and furthermore I look at this
constraints and the order
preferences this row really like every
coordinate where Act is positive to the
okay so in
particular this solution here
one1 does not dominate the coordinate
correspond to uh D1 and H2 because D1 H2
are actually blocking uh this mat so
there's two constraint here that is
possible uh to block but both of these
constraint the match matchings actually
like it more than the existing positive
coordinations
okay uh so a dominating
Solutions is uh a solution that
dominates every column that's the
definition so scar LMA 67 said that give
me a
matrix give me some sort of strict oring
on these columns for every rows there
will be an extreme point of this polop
that dominates every column of a this is
a beautiful theorem that he's came up to
prove the nonempty core of the balance
game
um and here if we apply this uh if p is
a polytop the biper graph we know from
VJ talk that is an integer polytop then
all the extreme points are integer and
by this theorem the extreme point the
integer correspond to a stable matching
therefore we have a alternative proof to
show that there's a stable matching in
bag
okay uh so why is it good well it is
good because we can use the same concept
to extend it to matching with couples uh
so now here's an example of matching
with couple couple now have preferences
over pairs of hospitals and I can
construct the same Matrix again here's a
constraint for the hospital and
constraints for the couples and the
doctors giving the same kind of
relatively order the capturing the
preferences and I saw for the domaining
solutions now sorry when you given a
constraint for a couple yeah could you
also be for that couple D1 D2 can D1 D2
also have their own single T constraints
so that suppose they cannot go to the
same city and be happy together at least
one of them is happy yeah yeah so they
can have prefence over pairs of hospital
and and
yeah and
single gu now because of this preference
of a passive hospital we don't have an
integer polytop anymore and example here
dominant Solutions will be
fractional okay so that is kind of the
relaxing part of the algorithms um so
now here come the routing part okay so
given a fractional doting Solutions I'm
going to row it to an integer one and I
call a r is
good uh first only route the fractional
variables okay I don't want to route
zero to one or one to zero and second
this routing does not
violate the couple
constraints and if the couple constraint
was biing it should keep it biing okay
so if I have such a good routing then
and and I might violate this capacity
constraint of hospital this okay uh and
I call that new routed capacity C star
if x is a good routing xar is a good
routing of dominaing solutions then
xstar will be a stable solution with
respect to the C star okay so that is
the really the heart of this routing AR
withm have to be quite careful in the
way we route can we got that routing uh
so yes so the property of
the
yeah
hand W but
yeah any stable with respect to the new
capacity C star when I rout I get the
xar and I might I I have a different C
here be a c
St and you're going to limit the Gap c
yeah yeah okay so now really the goal is
to R in such a way that the Sear is not
so different from
C and yes we can do it uh the key thing
is that in this constraint Matrix I look
at the hospital constraints only at most
two number ones there okay and only one
number ones in uh the doctor and couple
constraint for every row and if this is
a constraint mric I can R such as C star
is at most C +
one it mean that I I you know increase
every hospital by at most one position
then I will obtain
stable this this one weakness of this
one is that it doesn't really give me
a other the directions of the of the B I
want to Bow such as C and C is not also
too kind of lower compared with with a c
so here's another result I can um make a
routing such that C is not
more C minus C star absolute value is
less than two two and furthermore the
sum of C star is between sum of c and
sum of C plus 4 so what does it mean the
interpretation is that we can somehow
switch some of these jobs from One
hospital to another so that we don't
increase any hospital or decrease by
more than two but overall the aggregate
job that we redistributing is not too
far from the
original so that is theorem so uh the
was C about uh so we run some
simulation on this data
270 doctors 18 Hospital run it 200 times
and it turns out in practice it's worked
much better so even if I have 90% per of
the doctor belong to couples I on really
really violate one position
okay um so well this the generality of
this approach is that well I don't
really have to require that the hospital
constraint have at most two it can have
three four five if I have at most K such
number one then I can find a new SE star
where the violation is K minus one okay
so I'm so excited I tell me why I have
this new algorithms that not only solve
two body problem but you can think about
three or four bodies problems I imagine
a doctor can really invite his buddy or
his roommates Jo with him and his
girlfriend to apply for jobs together
right she doesn't like it said that
please don't solve that problem H so I
talked with Alex t one and he's told me
here's another multibody problem that is
a little bit more important
right so here is uh stable matching for
the refugee resettlement problem I have
uh four families in these pictures and
here's are the size of family this
family has one kid one adult and one
elderly and I have three local
localities and each of this locality has
a capacities of how many kids uh so this
should be not Air1 but is really the kid
symbol some
uh and mention these interesting
variants
um can you allow negative constraint so
you don't want your enemies to end up in
the same hospital we can we can uh come
back to that yeah uh so a matching here
would be kind of matching family to
locality so that we don't kind of over
capacitated um these kids okay um so
again so in Refugee res the resettlement
we have preferences of this families
over locality and the locality instead
of having preferences over the kid of
the family it going to have quite fairly
complex Choice functions uh so the
choice function is really trying to
maximize the weighted weight that this
matching that satisfied all this naap
second stram so it's fairly complex IND
your program uh and and the
for each match is really capture the How
likely it is that this family can find
jobs in that
locality uh okay so this is a relatively
non uh substitute Choice functions uh so
we're going to look at this problem and
think about a concept called group
stability uh it really means that you
know given the existing matching I
cannot find a new group of family so
that
match it to a new family and given this
extra access they are going to accept
the F Prime instead of or together with
the old family that currently match with
and it's much stronger that is much
nicer than just a pairwise stability
because of non
substitu uh so so the way that we can
construct this back to the sca lammer is
the following uh so here again I have
the family constraints
and I have the locality constraints okay
in the same way as before but now
remember the locality doesn't have a
strict order on the family anymore it
has a complex linear integer program so
the way we do it we're going to make a
lot of copies for each of the match okay
and each of the copy we're going to
labor it with a set of price on on kids
on adult and on uh senior so that it
satisfy this inequality so it's really
kind of I have a budget of that value
and how I would like to distribute that
budget uh across the kids the adult and
the elderly okay so it turns out that uh
if I do this and I make the
locality order references according to
this price and I saw the scal lammer and
this at the dominating Solutions those
prices going to give me the Dual
certificate to show that the choice
function is actually optimal okay so
that's a kind of very nice way that we
borrow from the literature of matching
with contract to Sol a more complex
Choice
function so so the theorem say that uh
there will be a group stable where we
violate this constraint by a little bit
and that little bit is measured by the
sparity of the constraint measure which
is
given uh just like give you a rough
calculations that how much is this
sparity and how much is violations so if
you think about a locality have about
250 uh positions and the family size
about eight people then we kind of Might
violate it by
10% so that's working with Alex because
he has data on uh ref resment and we run
this simulations and it turns out it uh
in practice it works much better than
the worst case so max violations
especally for the feed constraints is
probably the most serious one is 12% and
on average is VI over
5 yeah what's the source of sparity in
problem the couple problems that's only
two
positions per reference the couple have
only two jobs and here one family can
have
multiple kids and multiple
adults
yes so what happens if
you so the minimum number of
people yeah that's that's the harder one
yeah so here are some other papers that
we did in a similar way uh so get back
to the questions of can we handle
negative uh so yes we can but do some so
level so the a matrix in the scap L
doesn't really require a to be positive
it can be negative and so we can capture
for example proportionality constraints
so we're going to map students to
schools such that a group of students
have to at least say some percentage of
the total student accepted so this is
the endogenous constraints instead
of
fix so the other paper
recently published we can actually make
that constraint not just a linear
constraint any monotone constraint we
can also capture that as well together
with with
priority um so that is the first story
about stable matching I want
to yes so I've seen things like this in
the trt of uni parte matching whereas
the market gets large you can violate
doing a Vanishing proportion of
constraints but it really there's some
assumption about you know the number of
the diversity of preferences growing as
the number of I see
individual yeah so the beauty of this
approach we don't need that kind of
assumptions any preference any number of
couplers any sad these are worst case
scenarios
uh okay uh respond to your
spity yeah sparity is just like the size
of the family that based on
that so so couples generally is NP hard
right right says some has a complexity
theoretic cor or no no so it use a scal
Lama which we don't know what
PP it's not an NP because now we allow
it to relax in so if you ask questions
that given this capacity is there stable
matching that's an amb heart problem but
now we allow it to relaxing and we said
that exist one so that's not cannot
really formulate as an N
problem uh okay uh so case study number
two uh is verian equilibrium for
individual Goods um so the relaxation
here we go a pseudo equilibrium and uh
the routing is a new geometric routing
uh that yeah I'm really kind of uh like
it very much um so the framework is that
we have M goods and each Goods I has
Supply SI okay and then an agent set an
utility X is a bundle in this subset of
uh feasible bundles and the utility
depends on which bundle I'm consuming
and how much money left over for okay I
don't require quashi linearity at all
and I assume only that this utility is
going to be continuous in the money and
strictly
decreasing so the choice correspondent
so this is standard uh so for every P
Price an agent going to look at what are
the bundles that optimize the utility uh
the competitive equilibriums will be a
pair surprise and Bun bundles uh such
that that H bundles in the choice
correspondence and I sum up all the
bundles the agregate one will less than
the capacity and um it have to be equal
Market clear if the price is
positive I call it an alpha approximate
comparative equilibrium if this price
and allocations is an equilibrium where
I change the capacity by an
alpha good
yeah uh so what do we know about the
existence of comparative equilibrium for
this so there's two kind of
subcategories if quash linear utility
which is the value bundles minus the
money then we know a little bit more
right so we know that grass substitute
is equivalent to single Improvement to
uh no
complementarities then uh we know that
equilibrium exist so recent paper B and
camper show that this lotion a
unimodular type for the prefence in
quinia also guarantee the existence of
equ so in
nasia we know
that the notion substitute but it's not
in that way it's mean that if I increase
of price no other Goods demands going go
down that also guarantee the existing of
equilibrium and recently bin at get the
new notion called net substitute really
playing with the kind of Martial and hix
and demand little bit complex okay uh so
we want to bring little bit new insight
into the literature uh we define a class
called Delta substitute I'm not going to
tell now in a moment next slides if
utility are Delta substitute then there
will be two time Delta minus one
approximate
comparative so in particular if I choose
Delta equal to one I'm going to have a
exact competitive equili okay and even
in that Notions we expanding the
literature so it turns out it does
capture the question linear case it
doesn't capture the UN modular type but
we can modify the proof to get that
result as well for non qu linear on
subjective is a
strict uh more General than
substitute uh if also more General than
n
substitute now you can bring this
property of single Improvement and no
complementary to the non quashy linear
as well okay and in the non linear these
concept are not really equivalent like
in line
case so what is Delta substitute it's
very simple so Delta substitute say that
if I look at all the choice
correspondence of the agents if it's
contain more than one bundles it has to
be the case there two bundles that I can
switch from one to another by exchange
atmost
Delta so the things that in X is there's
atmost Delta stuff things that in y but
not in X also at most
Delta Delta in one it mean that I can
exchange one one exchange to get from
one
B so
substitute X by y by exchange at most
Delta okay so here's two interesting
subass of Delta substitute first one
would be kind of imitating the uh
substitute uh in Nashi linear that if I
increase a price of a single good I'm
looking how many other Goods I'm allowed
to decrease my demand it's at at most
Delta
others then if it's the case then this
is a subass of Delta plus one
uh the second would be the Delta
Improvement let say that if I after the
price p and com consuming this xand
which is not
optimal then I can improve it by
exchange at most Delta okay so both of
these are really strict glass of Delta
subject so what is a proof idea uh how
do we do that so the idea is that we
look at this eony we relax it
by assuming that agents can consume
lotteries okay uh so now agents demands
are going to be sitting in the convex h
of the choice correspondence instead of
the vertices of the choice
correspondence okay uh so now with that
it really show the discontinuity of the
discret good I can get that pseudo
equilibrium but now it's it's sitting
right in the middle of this
PO so what I really want to do do is to
round this yellow Point into the
vertexes of this point okay and I red it
so that I get an S
Prime if S Prime are not too far from s
then I really get a very good
approximate compared to make
sensetive at the price P each note of
the PO each vertex is in the choice
question Bond it but now I'm allowing to
consume any fractional allocation inside
that
Bo now I'm rounded to a Vertex that it
mean that it's in the choice
correspondent but in this fractional
solution theand Supply yeah
yeah yes
yes that's a bit reminiscent of what
gener equum the
the exactly
yeah uh so a little bit different here
that the way we measure the distance in
shment we don't authorize in the case
when Delta is larger than one to
increase the resources that yeah I will
come back to that so here is uh
oops right so it's that if my utility is
Delta substitute then this convex h of
the choice cor has a very nice property
in particular if I look at the edges of
this polop it's quite short it contain
atmost Delta number ones and atmost
Delta minus one this really correspond
to the way I
defy the the Delta substitute it can
exchange one to another by sweeping at
most Delta Goods okay and here's the
Lama that I'm quite proud of if every
polytop satisfy that
Property Delta uniform then you can
route it so that
the maximum of every good that I violate
is at most two
Del okay so this is a scale free bow it
doesn't depend on the dimension just
depend on the structure of this polytop
which is different from fman shly fman
theorem is constructive wondering so you
don't know how
toing so how about this one easy
yeah
y yeah so it it based on Geometry and
linear algebra so every time basically
you look
at the mean sum of this PO and look at
the minimum phase that contain your
Solutions okay and by clever calculation
you said that oh because it's in minimum
phase you can find a constraint
somewhere on the resource constraint
that you can drop it out without
violating that constraint now you drop a
constraint out you can lower the
dimensions of a minimum phase you
continue doing that you're going to get
to a vertex of that nucle this is kind
interative routing but based on
Geometry okay uh good uh case number two
uh Pudo Market
implementations uh so here we have a
different environment when we have no
money like the previous case the uity
are cardal and agents can consume
lotteries and they're going to take the
expectations of that Lottery okay uh so
again I have am good agent has budget
now uh and utility for bundle is
ujx and for lottery tier is a lottery
it's just the expectations of that
Lottery okay um so the random demand or
random Choice correspondent if I give
you a price p over the items and a
budget BJ you're going to go around and
find what as the optimal lotteries that
are consuming to maximize my
expectations uh with the constraint that
my expected budget is satisf
okay so competitive equilibrium over the
lottery shares
exactly this right a price and bunch of
lotteries satisfying that each of the
lottery is optimal for every agent and I
sum of the expectation of the lottery it
has to satisfy the capacity con and it's
going to be equal if the price is B make
sense um so now I have a competitive
equilibri over the lotteries I need to
implement it somehow uh the
implementation is say that uh this can
be implementable if I can give you a
lottery over feasible allocation where
every agents get the optimal M optimal
Lottery
okay so this is really just
generalization from framework of
Highland and zuser uh for unit Demand
right so in hel hex hous if agents are
consuming single uh item then we know
that equ equilibrium exist and it can be
implemented because Lo of
volum okay so when agents consume a
bundle then we still have the first part
but not the second
part let me show you an
example somehow we end up with an
competitive equilibrium over the lottery
share where I consume the bundle of the
car and the tool with half probability
my why consume the car and the key with
half probability and my key consume the
key and the two with half probability I
cannot really implement this right look
one way I can implement it is half of
the time I get the car and the twool my
why get the key half of the
time the kid get the key and the tool
and my wife get the car she's not going
to be happy
right so another option is I'm getting
the car and the tool the kids get the
key my wife going to get the car and the
key and the kids get the tool may be
reasonable but I really have to convince
my kid that his utilities are additive
which might involves a lot of
tears but also implementations here in
this example is not possible unless we
assume some structure about the utility
functions in particular additive in this
case Okay um so theorem Go pass and doo
Z prove that if these valuations are
substitut then you can do
it so the proof is quite complex it's
show by a limit of sequence of
equilibrium uh in a setting with money
and it conver conver more to more to a
setting when there's no money uh so
rakash and I 2001 proed that actually if
the valuations are Delta
substitute then any competitive
equilibrium over the outcome you can
implement it over with the violation of
two data minus one so the difference
here is that any and also General to
Delta
sub and it's really based on the re
relax and rout approach here right we
relax to competitive equilibrium over
Lottery and why is it routing when we
thinking about the implementations
because the routings actually give keep
you the implementation think about it
right so we have a fractional
Solutions swh here and if it is possible
that we round it to integer in every
directions right I take that direction
and i r it to this guy and I take that
direction and i r it to this guy that to
this guy then the fractional solution is
inside
the convex of all this integer Po and
that give me exactly the implementations
of that fractional
solution so this really kind of based on
the routing in server directions that
give me the
implementation so Alex and I talk a
little bit about this proof and it turns
out that we can really cut the essential
and boid out to why do this
work for the implementations and it
turns out that it's work very general so
you can define a class of valuation that
is invariant if we in the class I can
add up any linear function to it it's
still in that
class so the theorem say that
competitive equilibrium in the economy
with money was linear exists if and only
it any equilibrium in this no money of
the probability share can be
implemented so here kind of the
implications right so we know that now
the equilibrium in the tum sharly Sher
talk about is actually equivalent to
Highland
hous okay now you can say that the car
and C actually equivalent to the buddish
at a result of implement uh random
bundles and we can obtain s other new
results as
well I have is that five minut 10
minutes uh so moreover this kind of the
maximum domain that can carry over
because of this equivalent this is SC of
Maximum domain that say substitute is
the largest class over certain
conditions that guarantee the
equilibrium exist in the sashy linear
case so we can import that into uh the
implemented
result as
well very good um so the key element of
the proof is actually quite
simple so I look at the random Choice
which is really character what are the
optimal lotteries that I can consume
okay I write out that's a linear program
and there a doer of that program I put
that into the other side of the C like a
l multiplier and it turns out that
actually that really the same as the
lottery over determin choice of some new
functions okay so that really helped me
characteriz moving from one economy to
the other okay so that kind of really
Duality uh result come into
place okay case number four approximate
option with budget constraint okay so in
this
model I am
having utility which is quashi Leia and
on top of that I have a budget
constraint okay and I'm consuming
determinist bundle so without this
budget concern it's easy right we know
that this is just quash linear if V is
substitute then we have a competitive
equilibrium now we put a budget
constraint everything is gone we don't
have competitive
equilibrium but we can Define some level
approximate comparative equili I call
Alpha Beta approximate equili if I can
change the capacity to S Prim the budget
to B Prim such that the absolute value
of which is at most Alpha and beta and
under this new capacity new budget I
have a competitive
make
sense so the theorem said that if this
valuation is a substitute
valuation then we can find a price and
some bunders that it satisfy this little
bit complex form approximate
equili what does it mean just plock it
in for T So if I choose t equal to a
little bit more than two then I have one
time six Max of the PJ comparative equal
it means that I can violate the capacity
by one at the budget by six time the
maximum
price you don't like that six is too
much you can go lower you can go to tal
to one then I can violate by two and
four times the
PX okay so the T here really play as a
role to trade off between how much we
want to relax the capacity
versus how much we want to relax the
budget so just the idea of the proof
again relax and Route okay how do we
relax we relax from a deterministic
choice functions to
random right I want to consume a lottery
that maximize my utility but now
constraint is that expected budget is
less than VJ
for this random I can have a competitive
equilibrium again and I'm going to use
Dua to convert that random to a
deterministic bundle like before now
because of this I have a very nice
structure characterization of that polto
I can use uh geometrically rout with
respect to an additional budget
constraint to
get again I'm not going to detail into
much of the proof uh but hopefully you
get roughly the idea that relaxing R is
such a versatile uh kind of framework
that you can apply to a lot of of
settings um um so the advantage is that
it's really good it give me at least if
you like it's really a good
approximations Benchmark uh
and it really helps when we don't really
have an exact solution right and in
practice the additive approximations are
quite small um well the drawback is that
it's not really incentive compatible
compared with all the gitty algorithms
uh that we felt in love with but it's
unavoidable basically because you move
to a complimentary studing that there's
impossibility result that you cannot get
all this
property um the other drawback is that
we really require fix Point computations
um but you know experience we implement
it is quite fast and quite
reasonable so a lot of problems that I'm
currently working on U think about
roommate coalation formations all that
exchange economy you can apply the cab a
same tool there thinking about different
approximations as well uh so here are
the kind of the list of the papers that
I talk in this the lectures almost all
of them are on my website except the
last one we still writing uh but I'm
happy to uh take any
[Music]
[Applause]
questions the last one budgets you said
well depends on
substitutes to go beyond substit oh so
you can have out you can help out as
substitute as
well
maybe we should give a
[Applause]
[Music]
round